what an exciting night and I feel like
when hope calls is just gonna like blow
the world the streaming world's up how
exciting is it to be part of that it's
very exciting it's a little
nerve-wracking to be the first show for
their streaming network I really hope we
do everyone proud and that the fans
really love it I think that you do that
the original og series when calls the
heart does not do like what's the
biggest the biggest difference I think
we bring a little bit more humor to the
show I personally I try to make it a
little funny I'm a little funny and
weird so I just try to keep my character
kind of like myself so I hopefully bring
a lot of humor to the show yeah like the
cast is a bit younger like skews a
little younger yeah a little younger a
little newer you know yeah but we're all
trying really hard we really want to
make everyone happy and bring the story
to life so I hope I hope everyone loves
it
do you feel like there's a pressure
because it's the first streaming show I
didn't at first but you know you're kind
of like oh I'm here doing the show and
then you're like wow this is a big deal
you know but you should feel so yeah we
are we are all very happy and blessed to
be a part of this project thank you so
much have fun tonight congratulations
yeah have fun
[Music]